♪ Au bal ♪
♪ Au bal masqué, ohé, ohé
♪ Elle danse, elle danse,
elle danse ♪
♪ au bal masqué ♪
- Vous êtes de retour au Québec
avec votre groupe, la compagnie
créole. Il y a une histoire
d'amour entre usus et le Québec,
comment vous l'expliquez cette
histoire d'amour là.
CLÉMENCE BRINGTOWN,
chanteuse La Compagnie créole
- On ne l'explique pas, mais en
tout cas, nous sommes ravis
parce que ça fait 35 ans qu'on
vient au Québec et chaque fois
qu'on a l'opportunité de le
faire, nous sommes comme des
enfants excités à l'idée de
venir rencontrer nos amis
québécois.
♪ Ça fait rire les oiseaux,
ça fait chanter les abeilles ♪
♪ Ça chasse les nuages
et fait briller le soleil ♪
Ça a débuté par un téléthon,
en fait, en 85 et depuis,
on est tombé en amour, voilà
avec le Québécois et ça dure
et c'est super et nous sommes
ravis.
- La compagnie créole vient des
Antilles. Vous, vous êtes née
en Martinique. José, est né
en Guyane, Arthur en Guadeloupe,
mais vous vous êtes tous
rencontrés à Paris,
c'est bien ça?
- Alors, moi, j'étais à Paris,
j'étais étudiante à Paris, j'ai
fait mes études à Paris. Donc,
je chantais un petit peu comme
ça pour.... comme les étudiants
qui font des petits jobs, mais
les garçons se retrouvaient
souvent dans les discothèques,
dans les boîtes de nuit, ils
faisaient le boeuf ensemble.
♪ ♪ ♪
Et ce n'est pas du tout dans ma
tête... Pour moi, je ne pensais
pas du tout faire carrière dans
dans la chanson. C'est quand
même grave, c'est grave.
C'est assez particulier...
(rire)
... comme histoire.
-  Beaux plus gros succès :
"Ça fait rire les oiseaux",
"Vive le Douanier Rousseau
"Coller colle" ont été écrits
par le tandem Daniel Vangarde et
qui est français...
- Et Jean Kruger,
- ... et Jean Kruger.
- ... qui est Belge.
- Comment ça s'est passé là,
qu'on vous orere de tels grands
succès là?
- Mais oui parce qu'en fait,
Daniel et Jean étaient
collaborateurs, ils avaient déjà
fait pas mal de chansons avant.
Et même la chanson de Douanier
Rousseau, ce n'était pas du tout
une... Ça n'avait pas été fait
sur le Douanier Rousseau.
♪ Y'a des poissons tropauaux
pleins d' piquants sur le dos ♪
Daniel voulait d'abord faire
une chanson sur Picasso et
il a eu des problèmes avec des
droits, les ayants droits et
tout ça et...  j jour... il a
vu un tableau très coloré avec
des-.., puis il a dit : "Mais
pourquoi tu ne ferais pas
un truc sur Douanier Rousseau?"
Et là, ça leur a donné l'idée.
Et ctete chanson, en fait,
il a été créé parce qu'on avait
demandé cette chanson pour
la France, pour l'Eurovision.
Donc on a chanté cette channn
pour la sélection, elle n'a pas
été retenue et en même temps,
c'était bien parce quea a a
permis à Daniel Vangarde de
sortir "C'est bon pour
le moral".
♪ C'est bon, bon,
c'est bon bon ♪
- C'est vrai que vous n'aimiez
pas la chanson, "C'est bon pour
le moral"?
- Non!
- Mais?
- On le trouvait ça nul.
(rire)
- Je crois pas ça du tout, moi.
- Sii,i, mais si on ne la chante
pas sur scène, on se fait
fusiller par le public.
- Ah bien oui, non mais,
ça c'est sûr!
(rire)
♪ C'est bon pour le moral ♪
- L'album est sorti...
D'ailleurs le son est sorti
après, et c'est le premier album
de platine en France. Et après
ça a marchauaussi au Québec.
Voilà.
- J'ai une question difficile.
Je sais que chaque chanson est
comme un enfant, mais vos
préférez, ce sont lesquels?
- Euh, moi, j'aime bien
ananta Maria de Guadeloupe.
Et puis le Noël, "Bons baisers
de Fort de France" parce que,
en fait, c'est une chanson que
Daniel a écrite quand je lui ai
expliqué, en fait qu'à Noël,
quand j'avais découvt t en
France qu'il y a des gens qui
restaient seuls... avec
personne, je ne comprenais pas
parce que chez nous aux
Antilles, à Noël, c'est
un moment où tout le monde se
retrouve. Vous pouvez aller chez
quelqu'un sans être invité.
- Et on éteint la télé.
- Voilà, et on éteint la télé,
et on chante ensemble et pas
besoin d'invitation, et c'est
e e réalité en fait.
♪ Noël, joyeux Noël ♪
♪ Bons baisers de
Fort-de-France ♪
- Les musiciens de la Compagnie
créole ont tous plus de 70 ans.
Et là, au cours des prochains
jours, vous allez dans le
spectacle de JS Tendresse.
Février 2023 : grosse tournée au
Québec. Comment vous le vivez
encore ça, la scène?
- C'est sûr que, bon, je ne vais
pas danser comme avant parce
que...
(rire)
... Mais j'ai le souvenir de
danse... et je ne le ferai pas.
mais le public nous donne
la pêche. Bon, José, c'est vrai
un petit peu fatigué parce qu'il
a quand même eu quelques
opopérations. Mais pour le mora,
on a besoin du public et
quand on est sur scène, il nous
redonne la pêche et c'est
extraordinaire.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Sur la vidéo de la chanson
"Ma toute première biguine
partie", on voit une jeune
fille, c'est votre fille...
- Oui!
- À vous? Et semble-t-il qu'elle
est prête à prendre la relève au
sein de la Compagnie créole.
C'est vrai?
- Oui, elle est avec nous.
Elle fait le choeur av n nous
sur scène. Voilà, voilà.
- Ça doit être spécial de
chanter avec sa fille?
- Tout à fai c c'était pas
prévu parce qu'elle me disait
toujours : "Je ne ferai jamais
ce métier, il y a trop de
stress."
♪ ♪ ♪
Alors donc elle a fait de
la bonne médecine, comme moi,
elle arrêtée, elle a fait du
droit et il va finalement et en
faisant elle venait en fait avec
no p pour pour gagner un peu
d'argent étudiante et Ben ça va
être habilleuse et je ferai
jamais ce métier. A trop de
stress et trop stressant. Et
finalement elle a eu le virus
aussi comme moment et voilà,
elle chante et son mari c'est
notre chef d'orchestre aussi
clémence bringtown. Cette
entrevue a été bonne pour le
moral. Merci beaucoup. Merci à
vous, merci.
♪ C'est bon pour le moral ♪
♪ C'est bon, bon,
c'est bon bon ♪